la à ok j'espère que vous allez bien
j'ose pas le faire avec mon tee shirts
et j'ai peur de rêver net j'espère que
vous allez bien
depuis le 16 mars 2020 on est à peu près
tous confinés à l'heure où je vous parle
il ya plus de 2,6 milliards de personnes
dans le monde qui sont confinés a pour
son compte de la taille de ce chiffre
c'est simple lors de la seconde guerre
mondiale il y avait moins d'individus
vivant sur terre donc ce qu'on vit là
c'est assez exceptionnel au sens propre
cerf que c'est ni normal ni habituelles
et à priori ça n'a pas vocation à le
devenir et ce confinement il a un fort
impact psychologique sur nous et
physique aussi vu l'état mes muscles
c'est une vraie expérience de pensée
philosophique en fait c'est un véritable
t'imagines si sauf que la carte c'est
t'imagines si tu pouvais sortir de chez
toi que pour faire les courses
évidemment le confinement ne s'adresse
pas à toute la société et avant de
continuer cette vidéo je voulais
adresser un message particulier aux
aides soignants atouts personnels des
hôpitaux les employés de magasins de la
supérette du coin à la grande surface
les livreurs les routiers les éboueurs
de manière générale toutes les personnes
qui ont un job est essentielle et qui
fait que grâce à eux la vie peut
continuer mais voilà moi mon métier
apparemment il n'est pas essentiel
du coup je suis confiné chez moi et
pendant ce confinement j'ai appris pas
mal de choses sur moi cette chose que
j'ai appris sur moi potvin confinement 1
je ne prends des douches que pour les
autres j'ai réalisé que je supportais
mon odeur son souci en plus c'est
écologique qui touchent des basiliques
aujourd'hui 2 j'ai trop de chaussures
j'avais pas forcément besoin du
confinement pour une prise de conscience
sur la surconsommation de chaussures
mais là je me dis voie d'être levé le
pied nu 3 je suis hypocondriaque gérer
son de l'être vous savez que sur le
plastique et le métal le virus peut
tenir jusqu'à neuf jours selon une étude
4 je l'aï beaucoup sur twitch cette
vidéo a été écrite en live sur twitter
par exemple et je guide aussi une
méditation en live à 8 heures tous les
matins
tous les matins abonnez vous cinq jeux
procrastine même si j'ai rien d'autre à
faire c'est fou j'espérais toute ma vie
pouvoir être chez moi sans raison de
sortir pour descendre ma bibliothèque et
finir plein de projets mais non
6 je ne veux pas de ma liberté à tout
prix en quelques jours seulement on est
passé d'une société libre n société
confiné et donc soumises à la
surveillance de l'état
cette surveillance bon nombre d'entre
nous y est favorable dans une étude du 7
avril de harris interactive on apprend
que 48% des français ne pensent pas que
la sécurité sanitaire et conciliable
avec les libertés individuelles et
préfère privilégier la sécurité
sanitaire et 61% des français sont pour
la mise en place par le gouvernement
d'un outil de suivi des déplacements des
français pour s'assurer qu'ils
respectent bien les règles
et on peut les comprendre cela permet de
s'assurer que le confinement est
respecté et le confinement
c'est la seule chose qu'on a pour
l'instant qui veut faire diminuer
directement le nombre de morts
et il sauve déjà des vies
mais si des mesures liberticides sont
prises pour des temps exceptionnels
est ce qu'on est sûr qu'elles cesseront
lorsque la situation reviendra à la
normale comme à la fin de l'état
d'urgence avec les attaques terroristes
du 13 novembre 2015 ou le passenger name
rekord c'est à dire la possibilité pour
les autorités de connaître l'identité de
toutes les personnes dans les vols
commerciaux européens a tout de même été
maintenue et puis cette application en
développement
stop qu'ovide on sait qu'elle va se
baser a priori sur le volontariat mais à
quel point les données seront anonymes
ils le resteront
combien faut-il de personnes qu'ils
installent pour que ça marche est-ce
qu'il faut qu'une partie de la
population risquent un bout de sa
liberté pour sauver les autres
cela dit j'ai été surpris de voir comme
très vite nous nous sommes retrouvés
sans eau cubertoy de nous dépasser
santoni pose vraiment problème du jour
au lendemain on a tous été d'une
certaine manière
assigné à résidence ça s'est fait très
naturellement encore quelques semaines
avant on avait tous nos plans nos week
end aux orties nos envies et d'un coup
on a tout arrêté
c'est hyper intéressant à observer parce
que disons le ça ressemble quand même
vachement à des lois de pays
totalitaires d'ailleurs il est à la mode
par exemple il ya quelques semaines en
engrais le premier ministre orban a
récupéré les pleins pouvoirs
le fait qu'on puisse accepter ce
confinement si facilement c'est
intéressant car ça donne une forme de
prix à nos libertés
ce n'est pas un prix exact mais on sait
qu'une pandémie mondiale
bah ça vaut le coup quel est ce prix
minimum et qu'elle supprime maximum on
ne sait pas vraiment et pour être
honnête je suis pas sûr qu'on a envie de
savoir
7 je ne respecte pas assez pour bien
m'habiller j'ai aucun effort
supplémentaire à faire pour mettre une
fringue un peu style est plutôt qu'un
t-shirt de merde mais je prends le tee
shirt de merde
[Musique]
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à me suivre là tout de
suite sur twitch donc en direct tous les
matins la méditation à 8 heures donc je
l'avais annoncé dans la dernière vidéo
lendemain je riais les 1400 personnes en
live pour méditer là ça fait dix-huit
jours de méditation on est 120 à peu
près donc ça a bien écrit mais mais
l'ambiance est incroyable
1 c'est la bienveillance et de l'amour
ses champs mais donc n'hésitez pas à
passer
et sinon j'essaie de faire du live après
tout les soir vers 18h et donc soit on
travaille sur ma prochaine vidéo soit on
fait des jeux soit on discute philo
enfin bref il ya plein de choses c'est
trop cool
il invente une télé spa youtube je ne
vous laisse pas tomber les amis bien sûr
mon fief c'est ici mais je trouve ça
intéressant tester de nouvelles choses
et donc si vous voulez les tester avec
moi ça me fera énormément plaisir
d'embarquer certains d'entre vous voilà
il ya aussi des lectures de bouquins de
philo en live love peace bon courage
avec la fin du confinement on se
retrouve très bientôt pour une prochaine
vidéo sur un autre sujet et en avis je
vous parlais de ça je vous parlais de
voilà je pense que c'est important d'en
parler